[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kev mcguire they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
to the front pages then starting with
the metro it claims that the prime
minister's speech to the conservative
party conference today contained plenty
of jokes but was light on policy detail
built back banter
mr johnson's 44-minute speech has been
attracting the same criticism from
northern leaders that's in the yorkshire
post
but the telegraph disagrees pointing to
his statement about not building homes
on green fields
the guardian is blistering quoting the
business think tank the adam smith
institute which described the address as
vacuous and bombastic
similarly the times says boris johnson's
now now faces a backlash from pro-brexit
business leaders who are unhappy with
rising costs
meanwhile the daily mail reports on the
high court's findings that the ruler of
dubai sheikh
al maktoum broke the law by hacking the
phones of his estranged wife and members
of her legal team
financial times reporting that gas
prices
saw today then plummeted having hit
10-year highs after russian president
vladimir putin signaled his intention to
assist with europe's supply problems
experts are apparently skeptical of his
moves
so let's hear more from andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire not resounding thumbs
up from the newspapers that you might
expect andrew what did you make of the
speech today
um it was a classic boris johnson uh
speech it was um uh
it was barnstorming it was well
delivered he's a brilliant orator he he
had the room in his hands uh uh it would
have cheered tory activists no end um my
problem with the speech however was um
it didn't address some of the pressing
issues right now uh supply issues um
food shortages hgv driving shorts he did
talk about hdb actually to be fair but
but it but it offered no solutions
for um the current problems that are
going on uh there was a lot of optimism
a lot of boosterism some of which i
think kia stammer should try and um peel
off because his speech
he
he's so dull and brave by comparison but
whether this how this will play
in the
out
outside i'm not sure um i think it was
probably one of his best speeches but it
was policy lights yeah i mean kevin it
was genuinely funny and entertaining in
parts was it not but that's the question
for everybody it's the reality versus
the optimism bid um dismissing the the
current crises be they gas or uh petrol
uh the answer to present stresses and
strains he said which are mainly a
function of growth and economic revival
is not to reach that same old lever of
uncontrolled immigration
i mean you know it's meant to cheer
people up in the hall isn't it but but
there's stuff going on outside isn't
there
yeah no
look the entertaining part it was an
after dinner speech you could have
imagined him having a glass of wine in
his hand and he you know he had a few
beforehand but this was an 11 30 address
really to the nation that was then going
to be caught up by a broadcaster such as
yourself to show the highlights it's
going to be written written about and i
think you got the mood wrong and this is
what could be his undoing in the end
that the attack by kierstarma last week
that he's trivial
came across in a way you almost
corroborated what starmer said because
there is much as you say uh is happening
and that's why you get those two
conservative groups the adam smith
institute or right leading groups and
bright blue having a go talking about it
being vacuous as you say and what one of
them is is quoted in the in the piece
saying look people are going to tire
of the banter if he doesn't tackle these
crises on rising taxes rising prices
petrol and
labor shortages he didn't really really
address that i think
i could see why you would like that if
you were half cut yourself late at night
and you've been in your middle manager's
conference all day
but you know that yeah okay the hall
liked it but you look at the reaction
not just in the papers but you look at
the reaction from the public i was
looking at the opinion research instant
uh response of the uk public they
preferred the starman's speech which
surprised surprised me in some respects
because he thought stalmer came across
as a stronger than johnson more in touch
with john cena he cares more than
johnson he's more confident than than
johnson the only area that
was won by johnson is he seen as
less boring than star we kind of know
that but he needed a serious speech i
don't think that was a serious speech
yes interesting isn't it why also take
on business who explained really that
they may have been hesitant in in
reaching for investment because of
brexit delays and concerns and then the
pandemic why why attack them now uh
given in many respects they're really up
against it because of you know fuel and
gas prices themselves
this is a this is a prime minister who
turns to has turned the the kaleidoscope
upside down he's deliberately attacking
business and he's making the point and
he's got a good point that a lot of
businesses did
thrive on cheap labor from eastern
europe uh some of that labour has gone
back because of brexit some of it went
back to some of the people went back to
eastern europe because of the pandemic
but there's no doubt that eastern the
huge influx of eastern europeans into
this country uh brought about by tony
blair
lifting
lifting the uh the the the the
immigration uh shutters um depressed
wages in this country there's no doubt
about it and business can't wriggle
their hands and say oh don't criticize
us they did do very well out of the
cheap labor and those
that that is going to change now because
that that uh let access to that cheap
labor has gone which means wages are
starting to go up we've seen it already
with hgv drivers who were being paid
abominably that's part of the big reason
why we've got so few of them and also
their paying conditions are just
deplorable compared to what you get in
continental europe so it's interesting
that he's deliberately i think picking a
fight with business uh so you've got a
tory prime minister taking on business
because he says he's speaking up for
look for workers who want higher pay
that will probably play quite well in
the red ball and other parts of the
country and i think it's a deliberate
strategy it's also to contrast with
kierstama who effectively said in his
speech last week the way to sort out the
current uh uh uh supply issues is to
bring in 100 000 migrants and boris
johnson saying that isn't the answer and
i think that will probably be quite
popular
government statisticians experts
under uh
conservative rule have said that
actually migration there was
little if any evidence that wages were
suppressed there was some in unskilled
uh areas but only very small what's
happened here is we've gone from a labor
market of 450 500 million to one of 60
odd million and a few shortages create
huge problems and for instance a lot of
a lot of attention has been on
trucking and petrol deliveries but if
you look at something like the
the port industry where now farmers are
having to slaughter and destroy pigs
that will never be eaten they won't get
actually in the food chain there's a
shortage of butchers by the time those
butchers are trained there may be no
pork industry anymore because cheap meat
is now coming in from the european union
because we're not producing producing it
here it's a it's a huge gamble now he's
he's playing it in part johnson as
another culture war it's along with
statues and
union flags he wants to now play a
migration
card that's what he that's what he's
doing he keeps claiming wages are
soaring well
it's a statistical quirk at the moment
because a year ago in the pandemic so
many low paid people lost their jobs and
the ons
warns repeatedly that figures shouldn't
be used the way that johnson is not that
he's really bothered about the the truth
in these circumstances and of course the
government said wages rising apparently
rapidly uh was just down a lower paid
people dropping out a year ago and
that's why they broke their own pension
triple block and all of a sudden he's
not claiming wages are roaring ahead it
just ain't the case yeah they say don't
they that this sort of wage inflation
without the productivity in there and
and the skill sets to go with it isn't
the right sort of inflation it'll soon
get gobbled up by cost of living
increases um but certainly um there
appears to be uh with this talk of
immigration a continuation of banging
the brexit drum in order to keep onside
those voters who lent or otherwise their
votes to you in the 2019 election andrew
uh but so to you've got to keep the
shires happy which takes us to the daily
telegraph the pm pledges no homes on
green fields uh throwing out all this
planning reform that uh that was
supposed to happen
well it's very interesting that the
telegraph have gone for that line and i
can see why i used to work for telegraph
for a long time and that they are
addressing their their readers um the
prime minister said we will build more
homes but we're not going to build them
on green fields now that will be cheered
up in in the home counties and in the
shires and this is a direct result i
think of the tories losing the cheshire
man amisham by-election and is a really
safe tory seat that has never been
anything other than tory since the war
and they lost it on a huge swing to the
lib dems and the lib dems opposed
the planning reforms so those planning
reforms to build on greenbelt and
greenfield are dead as a dodo and now
the prime minister says we're going to
go back to building more on brownfield
sites quite right too and reused land
that's already been used quite right too
that's a proper good policy but what
he's got to do though is make sure they
do start building houses because that's
a key part of the leveling up
uh agenda and housing is a really really
critical part of it yeah brownfield
sites more expensive to build on i
suppose but yeah kevin quickly because i
want to get to the other papers
yeah because he spent a lot of time
talking about stoked poachers in
buckinghamshire which is one of uh
britain's uh wealthiest villages he was
talking about stoke poggers rather than
stoke on trent i think that shows where
his heart really lies sorry stoke on
trent you're just useful in the election
but the
target in the manifesto was 300 000 new
homes a year about 250 000 being built
now and the telegraph say
that uh that manifesto promise may be
another one that will be about to drop
because you're right that building on
brownfield uh land is more expensive
than greenfield which but it should
always be there but the fact that is
it's where do you want to put the homes
often where you want to put the homes
because there's pressure in the
southeast there isn't the brownfield
sites to build on but people who've got
a nice house in a nice village
i understand the nimby instinct but it
does shut out other people yeah just a
quick look at the other papers that you
were going to talk about as well uh the
metro uh with the jokey part of this
buildback banter oh we lost them all
okay they're coming okay um buildback
banter
i'm running ahead of myself aren't i uh
buildback banter after the buildback
better and the buildback beaver the
introduction of beavers and the
buildback burger i seem to remember as
well because the americans are taking
our
are beef now and the yorkshire post as
well just quickly lots of promises but
little policy in boris johnson's speech
suggesting that there was hoped for
details on regional rail this
infrastructure as part of leveling up
that they were hoping for that was
missing
more time to talk about that of course
later but uh next up how an intervention
from vladimir putin brought gas prices
coming back down after a big spike back
with that in just
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pearce
and kevin mcguire welcome back to both
of you um so to the financial times we
go now gas markets whipsaw as in they uh
have mad fluctuations after president
putin offers to stabilize energy prices
at one point going up 27 today kevin
this feeds into what we talked about
earlier about cost of living gas prices
whether the government's reality is
striking back but also that president
putin seems to have us over a barrel on
this one
no no absolutely anna and some uh some
blame and be attached to the government
over now getting alternatives gas
storage and so on
but the government is also uh
a victim of world events and can't
control them and vote voters could
punish the government uh for that as
well but these these gas prices are
incredible at the beginning of the year
it was about uh gas was 50p uh firm and
then it went today to more than four
pounds of firm until that uh real
philanthropist that world do-gooder uh
putin said that he could increase supply
and then it came down at 2.71
when you're dependent on on countries
such as russia for gas or the saudis and
others for oil you are in real trouble
in the in the world um and putin will
love flexing his muscles whether he
whether he increases production well
let's wait and see but he will just like
to know he's playing with with countries
in which he has very poor relations and
where we're at daggers drawn with the
russians and yet we are also dependent
yeah and the difficulty is obviously
with the uh the removal of the uplift in
universal credit um and gas prices going
up because many people have had to
switch supplier because their suppliers
failed uh the cap has changed obviously
too this is really tough looking at
winter for very many people now andrew
huge and and they'll be a real worry
about fuel poverty and um it is
terrifying to think that we are
dependent on the whims of the death spot
like vladimir putin um but but we are so
dependent on russian gas and look we've
invested all these billions of pounds in
wind power and there hasn't been any
wind it's been one of it's a perfect
storm it's been one of the it's been one
of the
i want to use the right expression here
the least wind windy period in years and
years and years which has added to the
crisis over fuel uh and there's a real
problem and um and i can see and that's
another reason why i'm uneasy about this
cuts in universal credit where only they
postponed it till next spring when
people could at least get through the
winter when their gas bills are going to
be going through the roof
kevin i know you want to talk about
saudis on the brink of the takeover of
newcastle united you have to read about
that front page small story on the front
of the telegraph for now thank you both
very much indeed good to see you both